[Music]
you're looking at the world war ii
memorial in washington as we remember
our fallen servicemen and women welcome
back to cbs morning's
on this veterans day we are learning
about a group of service members who
were denied one of the nation's oldest
and most sacred awards the purple heart
and also the benefits that come with it
a cbs news investigation found that more
than 30 troops whose injuries in iraq
appear to qualify them for the award are
still waiting for it they were hurt when
their base was hit by an iranian missile
strike nearly two years ago our senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge has the story for us catherine
good morning
tony our cbs news investigative team
spoke with current and former soldiers
on task force scarecrow who are still
waiting for the purple heart and they
question whether the politics of war is
to blame
the person i was prior to
you know a traumatic brain injury is
he's gone the pieces are all still there
just he's not coming back platoon
sergeant dane kassager was diagnosed
with a traumatic brain injury or tbi
after living through this
the january 2020 strike on al-assad a
u.s air base in iraq it was iran's
revenge for the u.s killing of general
qasim suleimani days earlier is that the
first strike yep that was the first
strike right there and the largest
ballistic missile attack against
american forces in u.s history 11
warheads each weighing 1600 pounds
everything shook
the whole earth shook felt like an
earthquake and then just pressure
moving through your body almost two
years later these are my hearing aids
cassagger can no longer do his job as a
drone operator he suffers from a long
list of ailments headaches yes memory
problems yes
vision imbalance issues yes my brain
it operates at a limited capacity all
the time based on the army's rules the
iranian missile attack met the
eligibility requirements for the purple
heart the attack was launched by a
hostile foreign force and caused a
traumatic brain injury with persistent
impaired brain functions but cbs news
has learned cassagra and dozens of other
soldiers who appeared to qualify have
not been recognized with the award and
denied the medical benefits that come
with it did your soldiers meet the
criteria absolutely captain jeffrey
hanson was cassagar's superior officer
and helped lead task force scarecrow
that ran armed drone operations the army
regulation that explains the criteria
for purple art it says it very clearly
it's not up for judgment it's an
entitlement and it's something that is
earned by injury
show of hands who's been diagnosed with
a traumatic
brain injury we sat down with hansen as
well as michael pridgeon and haley
webster who sheltered in these bunkers
meant to defend against small explosives
not missiles the size of a truck are you
suffering
yes
i've had to be medically
retired out of the army because it feels
like my brain is short-circuited is how
i best describe it my wife will say i
used to be so articulate and now it's
almost like a stroke patient i have
headaches four or five days out of the
week
the soldiers we spoke with all lived
through the same ballistic missile
attack but only webster who was
medically evacuated received the purple
heart
hanson said getting medevac became an
additional requirement to qualify for
the award is this how it's supposed to
work no
absolutely not according to this letter
56 soldiers in their unit diagnosed with
tbis were submitted for a purple heart
the soldiers told us only the 23 who
were medevaced were recognized what
happened to the rest we got no response
we actually were told to not ask that
question the messaging i was getting was
just the political situation wasn't
going to support more approvals the
soldiers said there was pressure to
downplay the growing injuries to avoid a
further escalation with iran and avoid
undercutting then president trump i
heard
that they had headaches and a couple of
other things but i would say
and i can report it is not very serious
that was an indication of we don't want
casualties right now and purple hearts
are an indication of a casualty last
month their commander urged the army to
reverse course and reconsider all
soldiers who have not received a purple
heart as a result of this attack it's
not something you ever want to earn
personally it's something that my son
can see as to why i am the way i am why
i changed
also diagnosed with a tbi corporal jason
quittiqua did not receive the purple
heart
last month the 22 year old took his own
life he struggled you know like we all
are like i am cassagar said they were
part of a skeleton crew who stayed at
the base to continue the mission the
soldiers told us they're speaking out so
that every injured teammate who's
eligible for the purple heart is
recognized
throughout my whole military career i
was always told that you know we take
care of soldiers we take care of
soldiers above all else
and it
it shocks me that
we have failed to do that in this
situation
a military spokesman told cbs news the
evaluation for the purple heart is an
apolitical process and they are not
aware of any directive for soldiers to
downplay their injuries the general who
oversaw the award said standards were
applied uniformly but a day after we
contacted the pentagon the army
confirmed it will initiate a new review
for these purple heart awards gail
that's good news that is very good news
catherine thank you so much it's
interesting to hold sadness and anger in
the same space when you listen to a
story like that a purple heart is at
least it seems that these these brave
people these brave men and women cost us
as a country nothing to acknowledge
their injuries right other than to admit
that we bleed too yes recognition is one
part but also the support that they need
let's try to end on the note that
catherine did that now it's under the
review hopefully that story will make a
difference thank you again catherine
herridge